how are you okay what's your
name he's asking what is your opinion
about oh I said shouldn't be civilians
involved they shouldn't be injured or
both sides shouldn't be injured it
should only be a if it's a military war
it shouldn't be um civilian
that's that's correct that's correct but
according to your book there's no
problem to why you say that
yeah
okay Samuel 151 what does it say he said
Samuel he said Sam God spoke to Samuel
and he said to Saul I'm going to choose
you as a king over people so God watch
out so God is going to choose sa as the
king over Israel so hear the word of the
Lord that's what God Said now now go and
kill
malachit kill their woman their men
their children their infants so killing
everyone why because the
malachit the on the they ambushed uh on
the way out from Egypt Israel so before
Samuel 300 years ago before Samuel
something happened happened to uh uh
Jacob in by the hand of the malachit 300
years after God telling some you to say
to Soul to go kill a babies and children
a woman for something done what do you
think about that God said it himself
yeah I okay if God said
that God said that he he he he controls
everything he he God doesn't say now
that you should kill there's no message
from God to kill me God is hidden since
the temple was destroyed I I'll show you
so that's a different story you can't
bring uh food from from thousands of
years ago go to now yeah but they can
because they're going to see we still
following the Bible if the Bible
justifies there's no message God there's
no there's no direct direct contact with
God so how could you say how could you
bring through from thousands of years
ago what there was contact so the Old
Testament ablated you don't have to
follow the Old Testament anymore you do
have to follow the laws but not but not
to bring Pro to kill to kill people okay
because they did them thousands of years
ago was they got a direct message but
you have the law in the Bible in
theonomy the law of War if you besiege a
city and it's open for you you kill a
woman that's in your book that's that's
called The Law of war that was directed
from God now there's no
Direction however they however the
governments want they do not not direct
there no there's no Direction so that's
the difference today so that law is it
for Jewish people all the time no no no
is it part time just from what was meant
to be them not for always to kill
civilians so he's abated
today anyone who KS a civilian has to
give a proper
investigation you what I'm saying that
look you know something about Jewish
people which Allah mentioned the Quran
you know you know sometimes Subhan Allah
us as a Muslims when yeah when you read
the Quran Allah Tau us about Jewish
people je people that will negate their
own belief for the sake of hypoc
hypocrisy have respect and be honest I
mean be honest how are you going to tell
us that law does not apply anymore when
he said the law in Dy was called the law
of War for the Israelites not now there
no godes doesn't even let who has the
Bible anyone got the Bible here why you
don't know the Bible I don't know the
Bible what's the question about on the
Bible he says kill babies and children
when now today okay what do you thousand
of years ago that if it says no if it
says it does say
okay that means thousand of years God
wanted that should happen because he
controls all of
[Music]
cre everyone that's why he said that
today's Times there's no justification
for killing
civilians
Samu Samuel is 151 okay God is just
correct yeah okay you see that's why
when he com to Islam Allah told us in
the
Quran Allah will not hold people
responsible for sins of others okay so
so so so what's happening now that you
are trying say it's true Allah create
everything no doubt about that he's in
charge of everything but Allah never
told us in the Quran Prophet Muhammad
told us in the war in the war you should
not kill women you should not kill
children but in your book God is telling
babies to be slaughter their life for
something has nothing to do with them is
that just does it say clearly that baby
should be slaughtered yes kill them how
they going to kill them they tickle them
of course they're going to slaugh them
they're going to Smart them with a rock
there was no gunshot there they're going
to spow to them with something what I'm
saying to you I believe the scribes of
the Old Testament lied about God cuz I
believe I I don't think it says about
babies it's it's infant here get I don't
know what's taking so long I don't know
something wrong with the Internet
raining today so the internet but it
says that say kill a woman man children
in Saudi from Saudi
internet I got it they came
it came he
came put it here put it here is
theke yeah kill Donkey he said forgot
donkey now it's about infants infant
that's why the nanyu the terrorist nanyu
he's an evil man he would try to justify
the killing of innocent people by
courting the Old Testament that that
doesn't make sense because even if it
does say in the Old Testament that that
was a direct message from God today God
doesn't connect you think natany is a
terrorist now a different question you
ask yeah of course I didn't tell you
terrorist yeah he's a terrorist yeah
because he's he's trying to justify the
king of innocent people by in the Old
Testament he shouldn't have he shouldn't
say
things I don't I don't I don't uh say
things on personal people like
individual is hit
terrorist is a Hitler terrorist Hitler
yeah was yeah why he was terrorist he
killed 6 million Jews in the Holocaust
were they innocent or were they evil the
Jewish people that he killed they
innocent yeah so is is he terrorist
because he killed innocent people or
because he killed the Jewish
people he he's inherit if he kills
anyone there was more than there was
different there was different uh Nations
also killed there wasn't just Jews Jews
Jews a thing because because Jews are
generally small am that's why it's like
killing um um um let's go back was he
evil was he terrorist because he killed
innocent people or because because he
killed jewi people and other people why
was he terrorist because he killed
innocent people correct innocent yes not
it's just a human Ked innocent people
how come
terrorist he orders the other one who
you said order the order the KOC people
yes he said because because he said ham
because H he said clearly I'm telling
you heed to justify it if he never order
it why he justify in the first place he
wanted to kill the people who who who
made the massacre in hit likewise he
want to kill the Jewish people that they
were promoting communism in this country
that's what he
said that they promoted communism yes
and there's Israeli I don't believe
country called Israel by the way I
believe a country called Philistine but
for the sake of argument there's Israeli
historian in a So-Cal Israel country the
university he saying that hit he had a
problem with the Jewish that were
calling to Communism okay my point here
is that we have to be just we as a
Muslims if someone intentionally go and
innocent people we call him terrorist no
doubt about that you know like what
happened 77 in London by so-call Muslim
that was a terrorist act what happened
in madid what happened Algeria is a
terrorist act my point here is you have
to be if you're a man of God you have to
stand firm and call the Zionist
terrorist natany as a terrorist that's
why he's a terrorist I don't
individuals who who who are you know I
don't I don't me I don't talk I don't
talk anything about them I just I just
condemn the civilians so why you condemn
Hitler hit is
individual yeah but he he's the whole
world he's known for evil person the
whole world know Nat is an evil person
as well have you not seen protesting by
a non-muslims even the Jewish people
coming out in London in New York in
Paris many countries around the world
calling natany a terrorist person and he
is a terrorist no doubt about that why
do you say that because you just told me
a terrorist who killed innocent people
Nyah he killed innocent people to over
14,000 women children been killed in
Gaza the same reason why you called
Hitler evil person and a
terrorist consistent and I know you're
going to be consistent but inshah Allah
guide you to be consistent you know be
consistent I mean you're in Britain
don't worry you're not in soal Israel
that will kill you you hear don't worry
even so I don't I don't talk about
people who are
alive alive I mean I I don't I don't
mention you know
like what do you as you call them what
do you about H then what about them yeah
what do you think about ham I think they
shouldn't have started up so what are
you talking about them you just told me
don't talk about people our life life
too you're asking for individual person
this you're talking about good yeah
individual individuals if you say a name
of see what what they call IDF IDF they
call IDF IDF your army terrorist
organization stand firm man and before
all of that you know what's your name
again AL what does that
mean
Al God as the king that I thought
so why we say to you first put that
aside even it's important but why it's
important than everything is for you to
be saved and become a Muslim to worship
God alone I worship God you don't need
to become a Muslim I think everyone who
was
born H into that religion what they are
should stay and not look for anything
better they should just should just be
happy with what they are how so so what
was the point for God sending Noah to
the people Prophet
Noah if everyone if he's born in in a
religion so why God s Noah to people to
call them from stay away from being a
pagan religious which is Pagan religion
to Oneness of God
you know Allah said in the Quran when
Prophet Muhammad came to you people even
negated Moses what you just done for the
sake of not following the truth you said
if you born in a in a religion you
should stay in that religion that's is
not God's teaching yes that's not what
teaching when you see a different
different in the fact that Noah God sent
him to a people that were Pagan
worshippers and he called them to
worship God alone okay but but but but
you say that Muslims um also worship God
alone and Jews also do that no you
worship God based upon corrupt the
scripture corrupt is corrupt scripture
the Old
Testament okay let me ask you something
now okay as a human beings we have
something called Universal knowledge or
Universal tools that all of us here
regardless to our background we are born
with for example that you are if you see
me stepping on a baby's head you know
that is wrong baby's head that is wrong
you know it's wrong correct it's wrong
okay if you see me slaughtering a baby
is that wrong a baby for something
happened 500 years ago imagine let me
give you example here imagine now Jewish
people go to Germany and they get the
children of Germans and they start
killing them and when we say to them why
are you killing the German babies they
say the reason being Hitler kill our
forefathers is that just no it's not
just so how come go that you believe in
he's telling sa to kill a babies for
something happened 500 years ago and he
just told me it's not just so are you
going to be consistent and you're going
to tell me when God said to kill the
babies of the malachite for something
happened 500 years ago is not
just God said it himself that's differ
no never God said that's a lie and
that's God because you know as I've
mentioned we have something called sound
natural ination like sound reasoning
like you know the most high he will not
never tell you to kill a baby for
something happened 500 years ago because
in your book sorry in your book and my
book it teaches us that no one should
not no one should be responsible for no
one's sins that isonomy and Ezekiel that
if the wicked be himself yeah
yeah the one you want to read about the
shouldn't
be can someone cover him you know anyone
has umbrella come next to him please
show him love you know show I mean show
him you know as a Muslim you know come
close to
him I'm okay somebody give him umbrella
is
you are our guest we have take care of
you show
you are you do the same one yeah so
song but God said it himself
that's now if Isis if Isis like killing
children and they said God says are
going to believe the no I don't believe
God would tell me to kill a babies for
something happened 500 years ago so how
you going to harmonize between God
saying no one should be responsible for
no one's sins if the father commits sin
he should be responsible for his own sin
how you going to combine with that in
the Bible the Old Testament with a
commandment killing the babies for a sin
that happened by their great great great
great great grandfather that's
contradiction we don't know what
happened thousands of years ago we don't
know what what type of uh connection
there was with God so so today's time
there for sure for sure not justified to
kill any civilian but I'm saying how you
going to harmonize in the Bible which in
the Quran is where we have it you want
to ask a question what was thousand of
years ago now is now you know what
what's now is now yeah but you follow a
book that came thousands years ago we
don't we don't follow book that come
follow the laws we don't we don't follow
what the stories the stor that law came
how long ago the laws of the Bible yeah
how long ago came up uh but
3,000 something yeah that's my point so
you still follow a law that came 3,000
years ago so we're not following the law
that came now so my point is how we can
you so you believe there's contradiction
in the Old
Testament okay so how can you explain to
us in the Old Testament in Deuteronomy
many books he says
if if the father should not be
responsible the son neither the son
should be responsible for the father how
can you combine between when God said to
kill the babies for a sin that happened
500 years
ago I don't know why he got said that
how they ask you why I'm saying how can
you has contradiction that's my point
and Allah said in the Quran if the Quran
was from other than Allah you will find
a lot of contradictions because God
doesn't contradict himself humans we
contct ourselves like sometimes we say
something we forget we say something
opposite of it it doesn't mean because
we in our heads that we don't understand
it there's contradiction it means that
it's it's not from God we have to it's
just a question mark and we have to
there's there's there's ways to but it
doesn't make it that Jewish religion is
not the right one I can give you many
one there's one of them here which you
cannot answer it which is clear that God
said we have to look it up and
understand there that we I have to just
you know Jews are just uh some don't
know what I understand that you can do
other other thing for you the Torah was
given to Moses correct yeah Mount Si
Mount Si the Torah the five books
correct yeah so can you tell me in
theonomy the end of Deuteronomy it says
Moses died in the land of Moab and he
was over 100 years old and the the
Israelites cried for him for many days
yeah yeah since then since then there
was no Prophet has risen like Moses yeah
so this this passages was given by who
was was written by who by by God how by
God you speak about God gave it to Moses
and he said Moses died in the land of
and he's given to Moses I'm not sure if
you know what your Rabbi said for
example uh who wrote these words that's
the question yeah that's a question
because why this words especially when
it says since then there was no Prophet
has risen like Moses God himself WR no
shows you a long time after it's a long
time after Moses
died what this passage which is in doomy
in a book which suppos to be given to
Moses when he was alive it says since
then there was no Prophet has risen like
Moses and Moses died in the land of Moab
so clearly this passage was written way
after Moses death why why do you say
that because it says since then yeah
there was no Prophet has risen like
Moses that cannot be said to someone who
just died today or yesterday for example
if my friend may Allah prolong his life
and all our life I don't think it says
since then it says it says that we we'll
never arise properly no it say since
then I will tell you even okay you know
Ezra one of your who name I forgot his
full name but one of them he said there
not just him it's isra
likewise you
know the one from andalia your scholar
your your Rabbi said there was no Moses
after there was no there was no Moses of
like MOS like Moses the son of Mayon
after mus he was someone who highly
respected you know my not sure you don't
know is well respect amongst Community
he was a big scholar big Rabbi he
was where
Granda Google my you someone Google I I
know what you mean what's about that
yeah him and isra both them they say
this passage we cannot discuss it front
of the lame and Jewish people because
why it's like secret because I I tell
you the answer for it some of them tried
to say that was a prophecy some of them
tried to say it was written by Joshua
okay some of them said it was written by
scribes we don't know okay so even
amongst your rabbis you're not sure
herotic okay because they wasn't there
so how can you trust it there to be was
given to Moses how can you trust a book
was given not just this one there's many
passages you know there's many passages
show us that the the the Old Testament
the the canot be trusted there's passage
we don't know who WR them you know and
also you can see here look you can read
it
for oh the grand that's what you call
him call what Grand
yeah yeah check it check it so so you
what would say to you
also oh yeah rambam yeah they call it
Ram yeah yeah rambam yeah you know he
was living in our civilization yeah yeah
was and Islamic civilization you know
and you know sorry I'm going to that
aggress a bit Yeah but sorry for that
but you know for the people to know it's
very sad that when you live under our
civilization we took care of you we
showed your love we show you respect we
protect you but when you go the powers
in our hand allow them to practice their
own laws and you are practice to you
allow to practice your own law but when
the when when when the PO has be given
to you in Palestine look how you're
dealing with the Muslims that's what I'm
upset about what yeah are you against it
yeah yeah what I was
saying take care of you know of the the
people took care of you yeah this is
very sad because when the Christians
they were killing you in I think they
feel I think designers feel very upset I
mean very like there all the years
they've been going from country to
Country and finally they got a state so
they feel very very um very like self
defense like they need to you know very
angry like they finally got the state
finally want to show they have power and
just murder everyone yeah so so so so
agitated no but the point here is if you
want a country you should go to Germany
we never killed you Germany killed you
Hitler not us Palestine belongs to
Palestinians you can come to Palestine
take over he said because we have no
country you have to allow us to take
your country over your country that
doesn't make any sense man you first of
all you're not allowed to take a country
before Messiah comes that's one point
and the point what you're saying about
taking which country belongs to the Jews
it is it is
place where where God said to ABRA um
Abraham I think that that that he'll
give him the the land of Canan that's
now Israel this this land God gave to
the Jews no no no no no no no no God
never gave it to you God never gave it
to the pagans ones no God gave it to the
people they were prophets of God but you
don't follow them firstly secondly that
country belong to Palestine the Muslims
ruled here for many years so if you're
going to try to justify him
if you're going to try to justify
because you try indirectly justifying to
come to Palestine taken over in
1921 or before that more specifically
1948 or 47 to come and take over by
saying because God told you what what
this all about man so as a Muslims what
we do we can take over Britain because
God told us we are the people of the
land or something like like gods in a
state AG I I didn't say it's right just
take what in one I didn't say I didn't
say it's right if God gave the land to
Abraham why Abraham he need to B A Grave
for him and his wife he already give him
land why he has to
be no he promised it he didn't yet get
it you don't fool Abraham anyway we do
no no you don't fool Abraham no way you
fool Abraham you is our our first one
who recognized God was he a
Jewish he he I don't know he there was
no religions there was no Rel no he was
he was a Muslim Muslim he was not there
was no there was no muslim there was no
Jews there was nothing he was the first
one to recognized God before him no one
recognized God Noah Prophet Noah Noah I
don't know if he recognized God of
course he recognized God he didn't
because because Prophet because he
didn't believe in God and and um um he
had very very little little belief in
God no no no he had a perfect belie no
because I'll bring you a proof because
um in the time of Noah made the AR for
the for all um God Center uh what's it
called I don't know Eng flooding yeah
where you
from London you you raised up in because
English is not
that I speak as aish I don't know all
Jew Jewish people don't have the accent
oh okay okay go ahead you about the
flooding flooding yeah he didn't want to
go into the ark until it was it reached
I think his neck or something like he
didn't believe there will be a flooding
he he had very little belief in God he
needed everything should be Pro proven
Abraham didn't need to be proven he just
he just believed in God you see Subhan
Allah you people your scribes your
ancestors you can see how deep hatred
anger the prophets of God cuz the
prophet Noah you look when you compare
the prophets in the bible and the
prophet in the Quran prophet he was the
prophets okay me the prophet in the
Quran the Quran the prophets Allah
praised them
Noah Isa all of them been praised and
been glorified but you can Des scribes
of the Old Testament the Torah you can
see they have deep hatred against the
prophets of God for example accusing
even the prophet David accusing Prophet
L accusing Prophet Noah is unbelievable
you know how can you try this how can
you trust the scribes who have a deep
hatred against the prophet of God
Prophet Noah had the a few people it
wasn't Propet no Prophet Noah had the
best
belief Prophet no was the best man
looked upon the face of the at that time
and even our time after the Prophet
Muhammad Abraham and Moses and Jesus so
the point here is I would advise you to
read more about Islam you know and try
to study your own book because you have
knowledge about it because you know
you've been clearly not you the people
that are scribes of the Old Testament
clearly they had like I said even they
had deep hat against God I'll pick up
I'll pick up God regrets God they call
God was was worried because people spoke
one language and they was they were
building up tall
towers is like the teaching in the Old
Testament
is crazy about God you know but when it
comes to Quran for example in your book
Inus he said God created the heavens and
the Earth in six day and the seventh day
rested and refreshed rested and
refreshed that's 11et yeah but look what
Allah said
in Allah said we have created the
meaning of the verse we have created the
heavens and the Earth and which between
them in six days and no fatigue overcame
us where Allah said that Allah to ref
the lies that been attribute to him by
scribes of the Old Testament claiming
that God rested and refreshed that's not
the nature of God to rest and arresh it
doesn't mean rested like a person it
means it means God wanted to tell a
people in a ways to they should
understand that he can't talk the
language what only angel so when he said
he rest was he lying speaking the truth
if he was what when he said he rested
was he lying or speaking the
truth speaking the truth but he didn't
mean to SLE the rested what people human
beings so what is rested he me he meant
to say that he created the world and you
know and that and this day should be
given that the Jews should rest but he
doesn't say you should rest he said he
rested he didn't mean to say it that he
himself
because it doesn't exist by God such
things as resting so he didn't mean it
so he made a mistake then he didn't make
a mistake he just wanted that the human
being's man should understand what it is
yeah okay we understand
if it wouldn't say that then the Jews
would want to know why should we rest on
the seventh day what happened on the
seventh day so when God said he rested
and refreshed for us to understand
correct so what we understand from rest
and refreshed mean he rested and
refreshed meaning he depleted of
something that the Jewish people should
rest and refresh no no he didn't say for
you to rest he say God create the
heavens and the sixth day and he rested
and refreshed not the Jewish people
should rest and refresh he rested so the
rest sorry sorry the action of resting
and refreshing is attributed to him not
to Jewish people okay but God want want
you are manifesting what Allah told us
about in the Quran you know Allah
says that we that the Jewish people
should rest the seventh day how should
we explain it
for the way you say so are you more
eloquent than God if who is God able to
say and Jewish people should be resting
on a seventh day it seems like you're
more eloquent than God because because
that's that's the beauty of Islam when
it comes to Islam we believe there's no
more there's no one more truthful no
more no one more eloquent than Allah
then after within his creation no one
more eloquent and more no one more
truthful then Moses Abraham Noah Jesus
Jacob Daniel Jeremiah and the last of
the Prophet Muhammad so look now if
because you claiming he doesn't not mean
that and you claiming that he told us to
understand him to understand him what we
do understand from his statement he
rested and arresh mean what rested and
arresh that's what it
means but not everything God not God BL
yeah blame scri blame the Lord yeah I
the Lord for the Lord said he rested in
fresh but he didn't actually because he
doesn't he doesn't exist such things the
one who created people doesn't rest andh
I understand that you no you speak from
the you say say if if you say God rested
and
refresh if there is if you believe the
plain verse like like it says God rested
on refresh he rested on refresh then the
question goes uh if how does it how how
could it be uh that that something who
makes humans should should need to God
Rest and refresh how could it be you
should ask scrib not me I believe that I
believe God not rest that's what I
believe in the Quran believe no does not
scripture says different Tex your
scripture says something else
though when it wrote that verse in the
in the Bible it doesn't mean exactly
rest and refresh it meant to say that he
stopped work he he he finished the world
he finished creating the world so he
didn't know so so you you know you know
how to say better than God now because
God used the word rest and refresh okay
which is in Hebrew as well rest and
refresh so rest and refresh mean when
you you rest and ref especially refresh
refresh mean you get re-energized so my
point your energy was depleted something
wasn't there you got it back again you
go it back you know what I'm doing for
you yeah I'm just trying to plant seed
for you to go back home do your own
research the last thing I'm going to
leave you with and thank you for giving
your time and I'm asking you why don't
you believe Prophet Muhammad as what do
you know about Prophet Muhammad first
what you know I know he has a Jewish
wife one of his wives was Jewish that's
correct s
no no no the full name I want get the
name yes but for full name come to me
saf her father man her father never
beli yeah she was saf she was a Believer
she believed in him where do you know
about him more than that more than do
you know he's in your book he doesn't
write
what do you know about Isaiah
42 what it say there I'm asking you what
do you know about it Isaiah 42 42 yeah
what is the ver Isaiah 42 is a is a
whole passage what does it say then it
says get get Isaiah 42 I'm going to show
you Isaiah 42 I'm going to show you
something very very I'm going to show
you something your we believe the Jewish
people in Medina some of them who
believed in the prophet Muhammad
utilized Isaiah two one of them
ISD one of them is a was not a companion
he was a mean he came after mamam his
name is
um okay Isaiah 42 go ahead I'll I'll
mention he says the servant coming the
servant coming to glorify the Lord
behold my servant who I have chosen I
have put my light oh I put my spirit
upon him here he is here we go here we
go okay here is my servants okay no no
you see this this the problem of the
Christians they like to play with go to
King James King James yeah because King
James said the Gentiles even in Hebrew
he says he says the
Gentiles he doesn't say Nations he say
the Gentiles King James so he says the
Ser coming he's going to bring Justice
to the Gentiles in Isaiah 42 he's
bringing forth the the Justice to the
Gentiles yeah who are the
Gentiles uh the Gentiles the Nations
except the Jews except the Jews okay
every Prophet all of them okay okay here
behold my servant whom I uphold mine
elect in whom my saw the light I have
put Spirit upon him he shall bring forth
judgment to the Gentiles the Gentiles we
said what the non-jews Yeah and we know
that every Prophet after Moses came for
who for the Israelites they didn't come
for everyone did they I'm not sure yeah
all I mean all the prophet includ even
Jesus all of you came for the Israelites
they didn't come for for everyone to the
giant house yeah don't worry that's not
the main point the main point is coming
he he should not he should not cry and
he bring many he said to open the blind
eyes to bring out the prisoners from the
prison and then and them that sit in
darkness out of the prison house I am
the Lord that is my name and my glory
will not give to another neither my
praise to graven images yeah behold
former things are come to pass and the
new thing do I declare before they
spring forth I tell you of them sing
unto the Lord a new song If you go to
Hebrew here mean a new law it bring a
new law and we know after Moses no
Prophet come with a new law all of the
prophets after Moses came with the
Mosaic law the Torah yeah but it's going
to get juicy watch this watch this let
the witness and the cities lift up their
voice the village that do inhabit let
the inhabit of a rock sing Let Them
shout from the top of the mountain who
is K
am K if you go Genesis
2533 Genesis 25 2513 in Genesis he said
yeah go go for show him he said these
are the names of the sons of is these
are the names of the sons of
is so why this prophecy speaking about
someone is coming to the Gentiles and
he's coming to make the people of K
rejoice and no one from the Israelites
came for the people of kada the only
prophets from after Isaiah who came and
for the J the N Jews and he came and
made the people of kada Rejoice is the
prophet
Muhammad otherwise who's the servant God
is speaking about what number what
number Genesis
2513 maybe King David did King David
take him
for never came for and he made made him
rejoice arms to Ira Matrix Churchill
arms to Ira 45 till who's going on AK 74
47 roll up roll up little weapons big
weapons weapons got them all who's got
it Morocco to M who's on
it
Afghanistan
banistan pistan poan
whoan who call the Poli stand in
991 you hear me now
Allah guide Allah cure him Allah help
him
man another
one it's that time against sh that means
you know you know Prophet Muhammad told
us Prophet Muhammad told us
after sunting the law of comes out you
know it's true true for TR you can't see
it anyway so that prophecy in Isaiah 42
even your rabbis they say say Jacob it
can be Jacob you know because firstly
he's coming for the non Jewish and if it
is your and what happens if it is you
have to believe in him why because
prophesies in your book your scripture
tell means that we have to believe in
him okay if is him it means the prophet
of God correct
he says it's coming from God God's going
to put a spirit and spirit mean what
Revelation because Revelation is a
spirit for people that that we are sons
of of Isaac not of isma no no I didn't
say you are sons of yah I know you're so
you the Jewish people are sons of Isaac
that's correct and the Muslim are sons
of from ibraim
so should Jewish people swap over to is
no no the point here is if God said he's
a prophet of God and he God chose him as
a prophet would you accept him God said
it in your book we don't know about it
but you just told me if he's a prophet
what is next I'm if he's a prophet of
God he's a prophet of a simple religion
do means that that that we we have to do
it with okay Prophet that's God choose a
liar to be a prophet
of I don't know the history of his I
don't know anything about no no I'm not
asking Prophet Muhammad I'm giving
General ruling okay does God choose evil
man to be a prophet God God always
choose truthful person to be
Prophet say it now if we accept Prophet
Muhammad as a true Prophet so he has he
must be a trueful person and from the
teaching that he came with he came for
everyone including you Allah said in the
Quran Allah said Allah said in the
Quran all the Israelites is isra
remember my favor on you remember excuse
me I don't want you to do go away please
have respect please we talking to him
please respect okay so Allah is sent us
what is that you bringing uh 253 yeah
show you so before he accept that is his
Prophet yeah now from the teaching he
came with that he came for everyone
including your B is isit and you just
told me God will not choose a liar to
convey his message so L dictate prophet
is a true Prophet which is and speaks
about in Isaiah 42 you have to believe
what he came with otherwise you be
contradicting your own book for
rejecting a prophet of God I didn't read
that I I didn't read it with steps I
don't know much about him anyway here
Genesis
253 what does it say this are the names
of the sons of
is what I'm saying to you historically
speaking there's many Jewish Scholars
that utilize Isaiah 42 to show Prophet
Muhammad being
the
[Music]
old let us do it then what you get
involved for we want to fight each other
what you what about yourself have you
spoken to a registered psychotherapist
about your delusion I am psychotherapist
are you and you are you are a Madman
really what what type of psychotherapy
do you do you offer I offer that you a
Madman yeah
right which particular School were you
educated at I want I don't have to go to
school I read the book of life the Quran
you read
fine I
read this gu read the Quran I'm of
course that's
why that's why that's why that's why
depression is a way lower in the Muslim
countries is a way higher in the western
world because ask them are you depressed
and they say
yes who that you know the government ask
are you any people you depressed no no
no we're really happy we love being
governed by some you
know this guy's a
himself I'm asking stop
reproducing reproducing both of before
you tell us you should before you tell
us go have problem with your own mother
forg you my mother's dead my mother's
dead go C gra them you're right I agree
yeah go C the grave first before he tell
us he has problem for us giving a birth
and he should go have fun with your
mother first to ask anyway what we
speaking about you know by the way let
me clarify something to people I'm
Algerian we I'm Algerian Moroccan North
African we be hyper so I do apologize if
you think I'm speaking aggressively you
know so why we say to you because I want
good for you know at the end of the day
I want to be guided like I said to the
most important thing for me no no way
brother I mean no way no no no I just
showed you look I just show you TOR
cannot be trusted I just show you I
answered back every question have you
haven't answered I did you just don't
believe that you believe that that
rested and refresh means rested and
refresh what it means then rest and
refresh it's just a way for human beings
to understand so what we understand from
it that that the Jews have to rest on
the seventh day no no understand that no
if I said to you brother brothers
Brothers if I said to you I rested and
refreshed what does that mean means
rested and refreshed mean me not my
cousin not this mad guy it's me you know
what you're doing you're doing something
called is Jesus what the Christians do
is when they insert their belief into
the text you know it's not there you
siner it's time for it's time for prayer
what we do make sure go home praise the
god of Abraham the god of Moses the god
of everyone ISAC ISAC
is that's for you no no the okay that's
wait wait wait that's in sorry sorry
that's in the Bible in the Tora watch
this before I go watch this does you
know in the Bible teaches watch this
does in the Bible teaches God said
whoever blesses Abraham God will bless
him yeah okay do you know we as a
Muslims we send blessings open Abra
sorry just open
the sorry open yeah so watch this yeah
did you do you know that our prayer we
pray five times a day we pray five times
a day yeah and every prayer what do we
say
Brothers we ask Allah to bless Abraham
and in your book God said he will bless
those who bless
Abraham in your book he says those who
said those who bless those who bless
Abraham God will bless them bless them
yeah so we bless Abraham in our prayers
we
weim which is sending salutation and
blessings upon Abraham one thing the
other thing in your book God praised
ishma and God he said he will bless him
yes it says
that I mean I don't know bro have you
read the the B the Torah not yeah the
problem is you haven't because I can
show you didn't know about Isaiah 42 you
didn't know about many passages in the
Bible we don't read much about of the
other of except the the five someone go
go I will I will bless
is Genesis Genesis Genesis yeah Genesis
God will bless is and God is not going
to bless you with this worldly thing cuz
the worldly thing is nothing to God God
will bless you with the more the most
important thing is a prophethood God to
choose you so that's why I'm saying when
you Islamic teaching when you look to
the prophet Muhammad just his biography
is a clear proof he's a prophet of
God we come from Isaac yeah I understand
you came from Isaac brother but I
mean what's your
name I understand but what I would say
to you is about following the truth
don't be like those why don't we follow
the truth what's wrong with I need just
broke it down for you that in your Bible
it says a man should not be responsible
for 1720 I just broke it down for you
that God said man should not be
responsible for the sin of his son
that's true okay but in your book it
says baby should be killed for the sins
that have happened 500 years ago so how
can you combine between these two
contradiction and harmonize harmonize if
God said himself then that's a different
story ah so so so you answer be be God
said it so God con himself God said it
you don't you think okay that doesn't
make any sense if go God does not
contradict himself God does not
contradict himself of Wars might be a
different story listen we're not asking
you to question God we ask you to
question the Torah I believe in the
Torah by the way I believe God gave a
Tor to Moses but I'm saying to question
this Torah that you have now that was
written by scribes who don't know them
anyway 17
21 uh 20 and as for is I have heard you
will surely bless
him worry BL your face
bless him when he was hidden yeah when
he was that hidden what you mean hidden
he God blessed
him someone took him I think they they
they um they threw him out of the house
or something of of of
um Abraham's wife I think I will make
him and an angel came and and and looked
after him
after yeah he was in a desert or
somewhere and he didn't have water and a
and a and a and an angel especially came
yeah yeah about the and God blessed them
yeah God blessed them course that's why
we we the Muslims are blessed by God
that's why that's why you're so
many the Jews are just 15 million and
the Muslims and Arabs are two billion
it's not about Arabs it's about Muslims
first where it's the same thing no no no
every not every Muslim is Arab there's a
Muslim Arab no no it's not every Jews
you Arab Jews in Yen Jew in Yemen
there's a Christian Arabs yeah so so
anyway what would say to you a nice guy
I said to you look go home and prayer be
sincere because there's no salvation
except by following Prophet
Muhammad no there's a few religion you
believe there's only one religion in the
world God believe I mean God says that
not me no yeah Allah
said Allah mentioned in thean the True
Religion with Allah Islam in another
verse Allah
said
whoever seeks religion other than Islam
will never be accepted of him and in the
here after will be from the losers so do
your study do research about your Bible
and maybe you carry on a speaking next
week inal may Allah guide us to the
truth may Allah the god of Abraham the
god of Moses the god of Jesus the god of
you don't believe in Jesus do you no
yeah you see we believe in Jesus
alhamdulillah we as a Muslim we believe
Jesus we love Jesus but the problem here
is I want ask you about something he was
a Jew he was Israelite yes jewi yeah he
was Israelite even the term Jewish to be
honest you can't is came after okay like
when I said to you Abraham was a Muslim
mean he submit himself to God according
to God's teaching that's what Islam mean
okay I want to ask you in your Bible it
says to Stone and kill the poate
correct PA said if if a Jewish person
leave Judaism you should kill him in
your Bible says
does say it say if someone dis creates
the seven stage no no no no get the the
the law of procy it doesn't say for no
reason someone just doesn't say such a
thing it says for a reason like if
someone does idol worship
someone the seven State yeah the the
problem here the point here I want to
mention for people to know why don't
understand that in your book it says to
kill a post what's the poate someone who
leaves religion J say such a thing in
the Bible
pass our brother here is going to get on
some just it never says something about
leaving religion it just says about your
brother if your brother or your father
or if your brother or someone your wife
inight you to come and worship the god
the god of the Israel that's what it
means become prate prate yeah that's
what you mean prostate you commit sin
you should kill him correct I think so
yeah yeah he says that he said kill kill
adult woman if a woman do adulter you
should kill her as well or a man you
should to death that's in your book too
by the judges yeah of course not by the
part two sellers they you have to be
clear you have to know say what I'm
saying it says that though it says that
what I'm trying to establish here I
don't see the enemies of Islam even the
Christians in speak Corner coming to you
and try to what they call the word you
demonize you demonize you by telling you
you believe weaponize the verse against
you believe in King apostate believe in
King so so the enemies of Islam
especially tomm Tommy robs and many far
and never see them going to Jewish
people and telling them how can you how
dare you believe to kill a poit in your
book how dare you believe you should
Stone a woman who are adultery but they
come to us and try to harass us so why
they don't come to you the question I've
been asking there's not much Jews around
there are there are man there are you
one of them you they're not a big
religion generally I mean Stanford here
who belongs to you doesn't belong to us
I mean like you have your own his
hospital no we don't have our
it's not Israel it's not is not is I
agree
that
bance ambulance ambulance ambulance oh
on ambulance because that's because the
the London ambulance takes so long to
come about Britain man Britain is a good
country please well if they come a bit
quicker maybe won't need if a man or a
woman Liv among you one of the towns the
Lord gives you is found doing evil evil
in the eyes of the Lord your God in
violation of his Covenant and contrary
to my command has worshiped other gods
bowing down to them or to the Sun or to
the moon or to the stars in the sky and
this has been brought to you attention
then you must investigate it truly if it
is true then it has been proved uh that
it is detestable thing has been done in
Israel take the man or a woman who has
done this evil who done this evil okay
uh the to your City Gate and stone the
person to death far right why not going
to starford Hill to where the other
place green seven or stford hill stford
hill oh is it yeah why don't you go
there why the far right don't go to you
and start harassing you for having this
passage about killing a woman or a man
because they commit adultery or prosy we
generally don't the Jewish people don't
don't speak out don't speak about the
the the Torah we don't we don't argue
with people we just keep it to ourselves
that's why we there's there no
discussion there's no there's
no there's no
debate you know Shar is not for the
non-muslims meaning that the law of
stoning adultery the law of K the
postate is not for the non-muslims
that's why in a Muslim in a Muslim
country the
Christian yeah Christian Christians
Christians and the Jewish people under
the Islamic califit or Islamic
civilization that allow to have their
own
Court yeah they allow to have their own
Court allow to have your own Court as
long you don't violate one of the
Islamic law but you allow it to have
your own Court you understand so my
point here is what I'm showing here the
hypocrisy of the F right I don't see
them coming especially because Jewish
people won't argue with anyone we don't
we don't force they come to us I mean
they come to us my point here is you
have the same thing you believe in the
same thing but they don't come to you
why don't come to you like like Bob Bob
here you know B the Christian guy
because you you you come here that's why
they come you come here too not many not
many Jews
come you come here Joseph Jewish people
come many of you come here some not many
it's not Jewish it's it's mostly Muslim
and more minority there Christians there
little Jews coming my point here is that
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
because they kiss your toes that's why
don't speak to you like this I tell you
that's the reality that's the reality we
come to us har us for believe you
believe
have pray abrah follow the footstep of
your father Isaac you want to come you
are brothers anyway you are son of
Abraham both of you son of Abraham son
have to go you look
same come on
man come on
man Jacob you look like Simpson I'm son
of
Jacob son of Jacob you're a son of Jacob
nice to meet you
abrah and
Jacob a I mean just have curiosity do
you have are you son of Jacob or you
just claiming that in the Bible doesn't
say you it says Jewish people yeah but
I'm
saying know is know I'm saying Son of
God Son of God he I'm saying you I'm not
saying about Jewish people I know you're
Jewish but you know in history there
were people who became Jewish yeah
converted so converted so I'm talking
about you they have a lineage that goes
about to Jacob be honest I didn't go
into it but we all know that we if we go
r yeah Jewish people the Israelites come
from
Jacob was nice talking to you and but I
believe in in the Jewish you know of
course you're Jewish that's right that's
why you're
Jewish but we advise to become a Muslim
inah we don't need no that's not the way
it should be we don't we don't force
people to become I need
Force no with words we don't we don't
persuade okay persuade I'm I'm you
because why we don't persuade we
actually if someone wants to come to our
religion we tell them off we say how
hard it is the 63 Commandments and even
we make it very hard for someone to
convert why do you like to bring in
people to your religion want to go
Paradise do a pagan according to your
believe that's the pagans will go to
paradise people who s yeah the people
who worship idols no okay if they don't
go Paradise would you not love for them
to go
Paradise oh so you worried for the Jews
that they should go before the Jews
before before before don't don't digress
now you said you just don't if you care
about people that shows you Islam you
show care and love to the people but you
see don't care about people if you care
about the people who are pagans and you
told me the pagans those who wish Idols
will not go to paradise why don't you
teach them and save them and let them go
to paradise because we let
everyone uh think from their own mind
come to the conclusions in
to pressure on people we're not pring
people we're not pressing no one we're
not persuading
people whoever comes whoever comes in
the own mind to want to become Jewish
and then so when Moses came to Pharaoh
what did he say to Pharaoh he say say to
him let the people of the Israelites Go
free oh God will destroy you yeah so why
would TR to persuade
him because the Jewish people are not
meant to be slaves in Egypt that's what
I'm saying you care about your own
people you don't care about other people
but Islam teach us to care about
everyone anyway I'm not trying to force
you but nothing but I pray to Allah to
guide you the truth we have to
go we pray to Allah